oh is that who I think it is we zoom in
closely this is Santa
Claus also known as Magnus Carlson yeah
the goal of this tournament is to play
Magnus Carlson CU I failed the last
tournament in Guitar did did not do well
enough to play
him thank you Berlin okay oh playing
witty alien I believe is another
streamer not sure if he's streaming
though don't think we've ever played
okay no Stafford play
Sicilian I think I'll play what my
repertoire was in Guitar as mainly
studying
tonov okay we have a Smith
Mora yeah some weird like Danish Smith
MOA type
thing I think Bishop B4 is maybe
reasonable cuz generally the Knight
takes Knight takes we transpose into
some Main
Line not sure if I was supposed to play
A6 there or
not the last time I studied this was
before my final round in raiko
um cuz I Was preparing against my
opponent Smith Mora and we had some
crazy crazy line I think I'm supposed to
take this and then probably give back
the
piece knight B8 is a consideration
but yeah this looks
okay because after it takes takes I'll
still be up a pawn and offering a queen
trade if D6 Knight G6 should be
okay
what about Bishop
D6 yeah basically I'm just giving back
the piece like takes takes I'll develop
my light sword
Bishop I'm not seeing like so much
compensation for white although white is
trying so do I have like Knight E5 take
take
D6 there's F6 maybe F6
first
oh F6 okay I have to wake
up maybe
H6 then Bishop
H4 Knight A5 is probably the better
move was hant to play it
cuz the Knight might get stuck with like
B4 coming but I do get some
initiative Bishop D3 I'll play
H6
and maybe B5 coming B5 Knight
C4 or even even
B6
wow if I take there's Queen there's take
and then Queen
H5 that's
interesting
about taking
G6 looks a little bit risky but I don't
see how White's maing
me the plan is King G7 maybe bishop E5
Rook
h8 I'm temporarily up two pieces here so
all I have to do is not get mated I'm
okay giving back one
piece I mean why
basically using the strategy
to sacrifice everything and hope it's
Checkmate I'm using the strategy to take
everything and hope it's not
Checkmate yeah so King here has the idea
to me Queen H3 with rook h8 and then
I'll be getting the attack on the H
[Music]
file now Bishop
E5 yeah this is a nice thing about
having the dark bishop and white not
having the dark Bishop I cover a lot of
dark
sares got my wooden Shield White's still
sacking
things very clever play I mean my Bishop
on C8 is a bit stuck
but and now I'm attacking the rook and
the
Knight and the pawn and the other
Pawn so white has a bunch of things
hanging that's a free Knight
yeah I think white sacrificed a little
bit too many things
there Queen here coming to thre mate
offer the queen trade attack the
bishop yeah this game reminds me of like
walking into Costco like there's so much
free food like you walk in and there's
all these booths of like the free
samples I've really spoiled
myself I take the
bishop so I'm up three minor
pieces okay yeah Rogue H was a threat
too all right nice
start I imagine I'll play a High an
opponent next
round so yeah generally like the main
line in Smith MOA white play a delayed
version but usually white will take with
this Knight and
then this position I would play Bishop
B4 well we got in the game with some
transposition and I'm pretty sure this
setup is like one of the best approaches
against Smith Mora engine will give
maybe minus. three in Black
favor or the engine will just refuse to
operate yeah this line is so strong even
stockfish
is struggling to understand
it yeah why go to Costco and you can
just have free food in title
Tuesday evalar is evalar
working I think the evalar is broken
too I just stuck at
zero that's okay we don't need engines
today I'm going to use my own brain did
you miss not being able to play in the I
am not a GM event so I actually I wasn't
invited to be a player I was invited to
be a
commentator but it completely overlapped
with uh the tournament and guitar so I
would not have been able to play or
commentate I did watch the the end of
the final match between lvi and Pina
it's like very exciting finals more
exciting than last
year okay oh playing Sho we played uh a
friendly game actually several friendly
games in
SOI emote
only okay let's play some normal
openings yeah just following my prep
from
Qatar I played this line in round two I
believe actually in round two I got a
losing position and then had some
miracle
save Queen C2 and queen A4 are most
likely both has played this move against
me on live Icelandic TV a few months ago
but yeah this is all still prep B5 is a
nice kind of neutral ing move Queen B5
Rook B8 I can win
B2 um this is definitely not the most
challenging line white can play but it
leads to probably close to equal
position conserving a lot of time here
in the
beginning so Bishop C3 three I can
choose where to put the
Rook there is some
idea oh wow have Bishop
B7 so I'm threatening to take and then
take Bishop C1 I have Rook
B6 also some Rook B4
ideas
did I just miss Knight B6 it's Knight B6
White had
options Rook
[Music]
B4 he just Rook B6 cuz Rook B4 Queen
would move back and Bishop A3
comes I do have to be War if the queen
moves white will be having ideas of
Knight
A4
basically threatening Bishop F2
Maybe trying to optimize the
pieces have to look out for
tactics and now Rook
B4 Queen A5 Bishop B6
perhaps
Knight
G4 maybe just
H6 what do I do with
A3 have E5
perhaps this move
that's slightly
[Music]
annoying that was getting very tricky
hitting F two preparing
E5 have no idea what's going on might be
winning
material might not
be up a piece now
ah there's that
move
wow super
tricky
doesn't
work yeah I think I'm just losing here
unfortunately any
tricks would love to get the three
miners for the two Rooks
but position's so
passive
some Queen
atrick it's not working
though
yeah Rook C8 is coming
too
there goes most of my
pieces hey it's a
fork
opposition there goes everything though
okay H good game I got really tricky
there
somehow the tactics didn't quite work
for me can't be too
disappointed let's
[Music]
see I mean the critical moment was
probably around when I play
E5 and we got to a position where just
so many things are targeted for both
sides Knight D5 I was kind of oblivious
to and then the issue was that my my
knight is pinned in the very
end so maybe this whole line was bad for
me and the position looked really
Pleasant out of the opening
though maybe Rook d8 was
wrong CU I thought I'm pressuring the
queen but in reality it's the defile
that White's putting pressure on because
yeah my knight got
pinned
so uh that's round that was round two
one out of
two okay next game I'll play
E4 I played more E4 than D4 in guitar
only played D4 my first
round I went into the London but E4 is
um I have some more fresh preparation in
at least in certain variations so I'm
hoping I get to show something in this
game
all right I'll play Knight
C3 um play n a
three yeah this is a topical line which
I'll admit I'm not super well prepared
in but this is the one the one move I am
prepared for I Was preparing this for
mice was it round two or no it was round
three against Josiah
steeran cuz he told me that he um he was
considering going into this line and he
would play Knight H6 and now I get to
show some
prep but what is a prep castling
[Music]
or I think it's D3 first Knight here and
then yeah I'm supposed to delay casting
because there are some cases where white
can play
H4 and Knight G4 is actually the main
move here cuz cuz if Queen takes there's
D5 I first learned this line years ago
like over 10 years ago when I first
started playing Knight C3
Sicilian and when I first learned it I
think the engines would give some close
to equality in this
position but with modern engines at
least in a lot of lines I prefer White
Queen B6 is not a move I
like so prepared
for I think I'll just play Bishop
B3 one of the main ideas at least with
modern engines is H4
H5 okay Bishop G4 could be a
threat
yeah there's a lot of moves that improve
the position like Queen G3 Bishop
B3 eventually I do want to probably push
the pawn there's also the idea of f4 F5
as well the more typical Grand Prix
attack type
idea but pushing the H Pawn is nice
because black can't play H5 because
Knight's in the way and there are so
many cases where the H file is
guaranteed to open now is A4 a
threat thing is if I play A4 myself
there's Bishop
E6 so now might be the
time should just storm the H Pawn if A4
I play Bishop C4 Bishop
E6 I'd probably end up taking and play
H5 ah there's Queen B4 is slightly
annoying Queen B4 King
F1 CU Bishop D2 there's Queen
[Music]
B2 I guess black wants to play Knight E5
and harass my
Bishop although I don't really care if
my Bishop gets harassed
because yeah
I'm I'm having a pretty strong attack
with just the pawn the queen Rook this
dark for Bishop could maybe come in
someday
time is nice just looking at the clock
realizing I'm up a
minute Rook A5 wow so if I
take there's this pin if I play Queen
here there's Rook
H5 considering
F3
F3 Knight E5 Queen
[Music]
H4 F3 actually looks pretty good ah
there's Knight E3
though Knight E3 I take on
G6 yeah there's a line where I allow
black to Fork
me but yeah if Knight E3 I take on G6
cuz of this pin and then I'm threatening
mate so Knight E5 would defend G6 but it
obstructs a rook so it allows Queen
H4 and then the calculation is Rook E8
Queen H7 King f8 Bishop H6 Bishop takes
and then M on
h8 and we might see that play
out um I guess the king can run
but can it
hide threatening this Maiden
one yeah okay that's a pleasant mate
Queen
h8 I think black black took on B2
expecting to me to take on G7 with the
plan to run but yeah this was more
efficient okay got another win nice to
use some opening prep that did not get
to use in
Guitar um that's a nice thing about
playing a a classical tournament
especially one that finished recently is
basically with every game I have prep
that I didn't use that is still fresh in
mind yeah I was talking with joah after
our game and he
was he was actually shocked when I told
him that the engine really prefers these
lines for white um cuz he had also like
studied this line years ago and thought
this line is okay for black but I think
objectively okay eval is giving plus.
6 so objectively but also practically
it's um yeah a bit difficult for uh for
black to play do you talk to Magnus at
all in
Guitar uh no I
didn't I talked to Anish skiri though
had some Thai food with
him he's very friendly in real
life he's also friendly in Virtual
life just all around
friendly so next
game playing a strong player white
again
okay repeat the same opening another
Sicilian Four Knights I don't know what
to do against this let's just play A3
trying to have something
solid I don't usually play open Sicilian
unless I'm like specifically prepared
for what I know my opponent
plays but at least will have a fresh
position Bishop G2 and
Castle I probably play these structures
more from the black side CU they can
usually come from
tonov opponent taking
time
I want to play Bishop E3 not worry about
Knight
G4 F4 there's
[Music]
G4 uh trying to figure out my
plan
I actually don't know what my plan is
here just trying to improve the
pieces maybe King H2 at some
point maybe I can maneuver the queen to
F2 form the
battery Rook should maybe go to
E1 I don't think I want to play G4 cuz
that allows E5 and
then yeah I'd rather like keep the
structure as
is so Queen
[Music]
F2 Knight controls B6
now I don't want to play F5 too soon
allowing
E5 could play Rook
D2 yeah a small
issue or maybe a big
issue Rook
D4 Rook D4
E5 maybe it's playable E5 Rook
C4 Bishop F6 maybe I play E5 or or just
take on
D6 ideally I'd like to play this and
this although then there's Bishop
H4 maybe Queen E1 to go after
B4
yeah it feels weird having The Rook here
it's undefended but it defends attacks
attacks I keep the pawn
tension Queen B5 I have B3
perhaps I have Rook
B4 black wants
D5 also trade but ah Rook C two
happens uh It's
Tricky just taking C3
perhaps still up on
time guess I do allow Bishop E2 and take
C3
for
got the focus
here oh it's not good
very
[Music]
unstable
Yeah final position there's no hope what
to do opponent played
well
so allow Queen E2 in the
end I was under a lot of pressure there
I was down a pawn even though I had the
bishop herir Bishops were not doing much
it's a downside of having the bishop on
G2 and black getting in this move
E5 which makes me wonder if I ever
should have played E5 first
but not sure if ever if it ever
worked okay 50% two out of
four I think we are on a break now um
I'm going to take a small break and I
will be back
momentarily are you playing Budapest in
title
Tuesday not so far had one D4 game was
uh Queen's Gambit declined turned into
catalon uh not sure if
I'll I'll end up playing any like crazy
aggressive
gambits I think the the theme for at
least for my openings this tournament is
to
play my opening prep from Qatar so I'm
I'm trying to play lines that I was
studying in
guar I did get at least the previous
game where I played night C3 I got like
a pretty deep line I Was
preparing YouTube stop notifying you
about my
videos I think there's um there's
definitely ways to customize your
YouTube notifications
settings I think they still have like
the Bell icon maybe you have to
click okay round
five here we go playing Alex COV or
covor
Alex opponent giving me some small
timeouts maybe soon to be large time ODS
hey it's Yuri hey it's G3 okay we're
playing H5 cuz I didn't play H5 in
my okay trying to justify this in the
tournament I did encounter G3 and
guitar uh it's probably not the best
opening to go for but we're having fun
here and that's what
matters just as I was saying I'm not
going to do anything like
crazy crazy Gambit
wise all right so how do I justify this
D6 take Bishop
G4 play Knight
C6 and there's Queen E4 as well but Rook
G1 if Queen D5 I think I play B6 Bishop
B7 also prepared
[Music]
so what's happening take take Knight
F6 getting some active pieces Queen D5 I
have D6
defending it's a defensive Fork of my
own
pieces okay we're having
fun I'm down the
exchange and a pawn actually yeah down
what rook and pawn for
Knight but I can take on
H2 could start with D6 as
well kind of like starting with
D6 Bishop G4 is in the
air and realizing I should have an H5
emote I heard that move just turned into
a meme during Jonathan's
commentary still not sure of the origin
of
it but like towards the end of the
tournament chat apparently was screaming
for H5 in every
position okay so getting some time
Advantage if I play
Bishop what's the best way to do this I
could take on H2
First bishop G4 Bishop
E2
so I one back a pawn still down the
exchange Bishop G4 is on
tap that's nice uh Rook G8 and Rook H3
are off limit
my minor pieces do control a lot of
squares
here okay Knight D5 Knight
G4 move actually looks kind of
strong but Knight
G4 it's going to get
[Music]
Tactical threatening me I don't think
white has time to
take we might see Queen
E2 trying to
calculate Bishop
E6 I'm trying to calculate Queen E2
basically
actually considering Bishop D7 here
taking them Bishop
E5 am I
baiting might not be baiting
there I could play King
d8
looks very slow but Bishop B6 is now an
idea eventually Bishop
C4 oh that move I forgot
about have this
[Music]
move threatening the
Knight F3 might be played that's a free
Knight Rook HJ King E7 threatening
Knight F no kn3 Rook F3 but now I'm
threatening Knight
F3 I might still be threatening Knight
F3 or queen F2
there
there I guess I just take up a
piece Bishop G5
F6 Queen H4
coming will force a queen
trade okay okay that was an interesting
turn of
events that's nice
Fork also preventing Rook
H4 okay hey I won with H5 on move
one yeah there's really no other move I
guess G3 and G4 there the only moves
where H5 is
[Music]
justifiable okay I hope people are happy
now all right new game uh I'll play E4
again okay we have a French there is one
opponent in qara is preparing F4 for
f44 so now I'm playing
it and then C
three I think Bishop
D3 idea takes takes my Bishop's
defended so we're basically getting like
a fresh kind of weird looking
position I want to allow B5 though maybe
bishop E4 I could also consider
taking and Bishop
E4 then
D3 who is
this oh I'm playing Anand Grandmaster
Anand not exactly vishy
though okay so Queen
E2 just going to put my pieces on the
squares where they should be hopefully
most
happy D3 coming
[Music]
soon
yeah Bishop D2 rookie
[Music]
E1 maybe
eventually have some G4
idea I think is G4 Knight
H4
let's try
it so the idea is to play G5 eventually
and queen H3 and
Checkmate maybe Rook lift as
[Music]
well G6 might be
coming
G5 it does give me long-term
pressure I'm spending a lot of time so
far okay I'd like to play Rook F3
soon so Queen H6 I think now is a pretty
big threat black might have to play
Rook
E8 I just take take take
take
Knight C2 also
maybe simpler
move take with a
rook so Knight can maybe come
in and the bishop as
well
I like this idea knight3 Knight
G4 we might see some sack on E5 or
G5
it seems like it should be risky for
black but maybe the best practical
choice if sack I have to
take okay so now this
is becoming more
[Music]
real might as well take
first queen E4 might be
coming
H there's that
move
H this is going to be very
tricky throw this Rook
d8 I'm offering the queen
trade it is equal
material
R 7's
idea
oops
I really misplayed
this
should be a
draw can I play for a win
now
let's go I think my opponent had allo
queen turned on oh
wow
how did I win that I was down I was down
material was like down a a
piece I think the position is still
drawn after the Knight after yeah after
lack and under
promote wow what a game no time to
really cool down after that
one oh man so I'm four out of six
playing Ori
kuo just have to stay calm
uh what do I want to play just
take I looked at this line
briefly Queen
C2 I hope I'm not misremembering
I think this is a possible line though
just to defend the
pawn that A3 I think I just take
it and there's some idea like night A5
to defend the
[Music]
pawn like
here could
consider although I mean Bishop takes
looks a little bit easier to play and
then just
Castle could play E5
First bishop B2 is
coming King Bishop B2 E4 take take KN
move moves
F5 some D3 move take
take looks risky for both of
us which should just mean it's going to
be fun for both of us or fun for one of
us
interesting I could give back the pawn
but Queen
C5 holding on
Knight D4 is now maybe a
threat what if Knight
D4 just this first
I guess there's an issue Bishop takes
white threatening
D3 but okay I can just play Bishop E6
and Castle
maybe and Rook C1 is coming there's
going to be a lot of pressure white has
a bishop
[Music]
PA Rook C1 maybe Queen
A5 Rook A8 would be nice to get in
a rook
fd8 there's also F5 Queen
C2 start with a
Bishop D5 could be a
threat Bishop B4 I just take
it oh did the stream die sorry if the
stream
died got to stay focus
here
oh
dear have to play
F6 I still have all these
Pawns
where does my knight want to go
F5 he r f s
first maybe D6 actually like F5 and then
D6 to
[Music]
defend
is some idea to play
H5 Queen D3 as
[Music]
well G5 may be
coming
thring Rook
F2 I didn't know what to do
[Music]
um
yeah this should be winning
hopefully
there we
go not my best technique but okay get
getting the job done plenty of time now
too
for
some long games
here okay let's go backto back wins over
Grand Masters I do apologize if the
stream maybe froze up at some point I do
see I have some drop frames no break as
usual we
continue I think couple games in a row
it was the longest game of the
round all right kocan I'll play my new
weapon against
kocan whatever that may
be
H5 I did not
prepare interesting might just want to
Castle Queen side black committing to
H5 I don't really have a feel for this
position
though
the plan is G6
F4 or maybe G6
kn4 F5 is
coming
yeah 94
perhaps
F5 not6 Bishop G7 is
[Music]
coming I have Bishop
H6 ideally I want to play like G4 and
just attack on the king side as much as
possible
who is this oh this is
um yeah Grandmaster from China
janha okay
so I can't take the
bishop could play Knight
C5
take
I might be losing a pawn here Queen D4
Bishop f8 Queen
H6 G4 work in any
line
G4 doesn't seem to
work and queen G5 is
interesting Queen G7 is
expected G4 is still not
working so now I'm preparing
G4
F6 F6 Queen F4 I
guess
extra Pawn that black is up shouldn't
mean too much cuz it's double Pawn I'm
definitely the one playing on the king
side would mind to open the H and org
files
and this is a big threat takes takes
it's also looking
nice F6 Queen
E3 Rook
E8
I don't think it's ever good for black
okay never mind let's
take now Knight
E4 C4
ideas
Queen D2 as
[Music]
well start with
this Knight C5 is an idea Bishop H7
so this is a
threat maybe Rook
H7 C4 looks
nice
take Queen C3
first maybe this
first then
this the bishop and F Pawn will be
hanging in the event of take
take a there's Bishop
D3 but aon's still
hanging
[Music]
this should be
winning
for
I don't want to give a
fortress
ah I give a
fortress I'm winning oh no I'm not
winning that
there we
go let's
go let's go okay ah three wins in a row
against Grand Masters six out of
eight definitely due for a break as well
I was a really long
game oh only 78 moves felt
longer
okay chat has been in emot only mode for
a long time now really had no breaks for
the last
um and the last
couple games were last three games were
very long
so um I haven't had a chance to look at
the standings either I'm a point and a
half behind Magnus he clearly does not
want to play me keeping some
distance I'm tied
for top 30 top
20 what's your best score in
TT I think it's seven and a half I don't
think I've ever had
eight at least since I started streaming
title Tuesday on a regular basis
so would be nice to win a couple more
games of playing a a fellow I
am okay emote on
me here we
go oh from
India oh I'm playing roohi Krishna we
played in uh
be um what was our game in bule
though was like the Queen's G declined
all right let's play this B
[Music]
E7
okay following some
prep think H6 is fine
first
A5 I can Castle either way here
[Music]
A4 is weird to push a pawn and then
Castle Queen
side I might look to play G5
soon think I have to play D5 here though
I could also take
I should not have played
A4 it's actually pretty bad the more I'm
looking at
this okay this is not what I want Queen
C2 is coming so feel like I have to
defend the
[Music]
pawn
okay maybe now
G5 it's not pretty
though
h
Queen A8
idea Knight B3
idea time management has been really
[Music]
bad try
this
Queen's
defended opponent may be miss
out
oh this is so bad I have
takes trying to stay alive and the
Knight
takes Knight on C4 hangs after Queen F7
though maybe I take with
Rook really
take yeah this is good for
white still trying though
no ah felt like I still had chances
there I can just take the
Rook a rook's just hanging ah the final
position is winning for
back or is
it there's like some checks but pass Aon
ah didn't leave myself enough
time that could have been so nice
too had a chance for 7 out of
nine at some point the position was like
really really bad for me that's why I
spent all my time earlier trying to
survive and my opponent just like
completely missed my queen was defended
I
think cuz not F5 was a little bit
Reckless
then here like white should just be
winning but it wasn't so simple
especially after I won the a
[Music]
Pawn Yeah like here I was ready to take
the bishop so when this came I froze
because my Knight's pinned I didn't have
time to register I can just take the
Rook okay still a good score six out of
nine Oh My Stream just died
oops okay but I'm still connected to the
server I
think yeah sorry if the stream died
sometimes the internet speed is out of
my
control emote only off okay okay we have
another
carolot slightly different
carolot
have to remember how to play this it's
been a while since I looked at these
lines so
closely looked at these lines when I
played Levy but that was a long time ago
Bishop
D2
yeah not super thrilled with how I'm
playing
this I'm playing this very
passively I mean at least we'll have a
game maybe of some
sort this is so passive so far some idea
night G4 which no longer is an
option uh okay taking Queen
F4 maybe some G4
idea there's rookie
five is my colinear move for the
day could take with
Pawn I'm envisioning like Rook E1 and
then G4 and then take and then take with
Knight and invade
F6 this Knight would probably like to be
on
E6
if Queen D7 I might have E6 to threat
Queen
D4 yeah these pieces look so passive but
I think the overall structure is fine
for
white Bishop
E2 May
G4 so Knight
D5 that's Queen
[Music]
F3 take I probably take with
pawn queen D2 is
coming queen D2 I have Queen
D1 oops ah that was an important
Pawn was blind to
that
okay down the
pawn yeah it's going to take a lot of
work not to lose
this I do like the night here covers
some important squares
up a little bit of time
now interesting probably have to take
that
so Rook
D4 really hard to find a good move
here idea Queen D4 maybe I have some
ideas of taking now four I have Queen
[Music]
D4
and the problem is endgame though take
take maybe
this
for
threading miden one
let's go okay I want time
oh okay somehow Salvage
that opponent I didn't even realize my
opponent's username kocon lover that
wasn't a real kocan though that was like
a a modern
defense
yeah my play at least for most of this
game was
not was not the type of play I'm so
proud of but at least I kept holding
on and then yeah made things tricky
around here black should probably just
although King G7 yeah cuz C5 is
defended okay it makes up for the
previous game where I I flagged in the
the better position
so seven out of
10 right seven out of 10 one more game
if I win the next game I'll be my
highest title Tuesday score I think ever
recorded
okay here we go I'm white again okay
white for the final
game playing Legend Unknown Legend in
unknown we'll have a knight C3 a
so did have this position several games
ago where we saw
G6 yeah here we see a slightly different
line I don't have so much experience
here am I supposed to take with
Queen taking with Queen makes some
sense
I mean Knight C6 is
coming Bishop E3 Queen
B6 I'm kind of just making stuff up but
I think there's some logic to getting in
Queen
B6 I'm not sure
though okay so King two
delay Bon Cloud Bishop d8 I have Knight
A4 Black's just developing though what
what's my
plan your Rook here and then Bishop
Bishop D7 Bishop C7 is some some
trick is it working
though guess we'll find
out cuz there's no D5 like it looks like
I'm winning a
pawn okay so take I have Rook C1 to be
safe A3 might be
strong just calling blacks
Bluff so I don't think Knight C2 is
actually a threat
now cuz I trapped the
knight any Counterattack I can take the
pawn okay
so I think I just take the
[Music]
pawn really what am I
missing night
wow
really it's a move have to
take I take the bishop no I have to
take and Knight still might be getting
stuck in some lines like Knight a I take
on E7 play
C4 I definitely want to take the
bishop I could throw in Knight
E5 actually makes some
sense cuz Bishop B5 now I have C4 Knight
supports C4 Bishop a Rook
D4 Bishop a blocks a
rook now it's a
question C4 I think now c4 makes
sense F6 Knight
D3
I'm calculating Bishop A4 Rook
C3 there's B5 to save the Knight
maybe I taking Rook C7
maybe wait so Bishop A4 Rook C3 take
take Knight B1 Rook
B3 Rook B3 Rook
d8 King C2 I should be trapping the
Knight
yeah so Rook C3 what's Block
doing okay so now Bishop A4 I have like
some Rook
A1 okay let's go best title Tuesday
ever winning the final game in 23 moves
I don't think I win prize money because
even my best score ever it's it's not
good enough to like finish in the money
but I felt pretty sharp overall this
tournament did have a lot of games kind
of go my
way thanks everyone for being here for
this special
moment yeah definitely definitely help
to have just finished a classical
tournament hello to YouTube hello to the
main channel uh yeah I usually post the
title Tuesday videos on the extra
Channel but this is a special one I
started the tournament like 2560
something so I gained about 60
points okay it's over I finished in
26th anyway um thanks everyone for
tuning in if this goes on YouTube uh
I'll Tim stamp every game in the
description as like a chapter so
let me know what your favorite game was